In this portion of our course, we begin by looking at the complexity of the metahuman
face.
Then, we delve into metahuman DNA, the DNA calibration repository, and go over expectations
for achieving likeness with our characters.
Let's get started by first exploring the complexity of the metahuman face.
In this section of our course, we begin by looking at the complexity of the metahuman
face.
We will take a look at the metahuman face component and its associated assets, including
all of its geometry and how these work with rig logic.
Let's begin by answering the question, what is the metahuman framework?
The metahuman framework is a single product made up of a variety of collaborating parts,
carefully designed to work together seamlessly.
The assets that make up the metahuman framework include the body and head meshes, skeletons
and control rigs, animation blueprints, materials and animated maps, clothing, grooms, metahuman
DNA and rig logic.
In this course, we are focused on one of those assets, the metahuman face.
The face is tied to all of these assets, and for this reason, a few things should be considered
when making modifications to the neutral pose so that it behaves correctly.
The metahuman face component is made up of several assets.
Let's take a look at the head geometry first.
Inside of Maya, we can see the assets that make up the head geometry.
These meshes include the head, the teeth, the saliva, the left and right eye, the eye
shell, the eyelashes, the eye edge and cartilage.
And each of these have their own LODs.
There are also the joints, skin clusters and blend shapes.
Now let's take a look at the assets that make up the metahuman face component in Unreal
Engine.
In Unreal Engine, the face component assets include the skeleton, the skeletal mesh, animation
sequences, animation blueprints and the face pose process animation blueprint.
As we saw in the metahuman blueprint and animation course, the face pose process animation blueprint
is where the rig logic node lives, and is responsible for triggering the animated blood
flow and normal maps.
Now let's delve into rig logic a bit more.
Rig logic is a runtime, facial rig evaluation solver system developed by 3Lateral and has
taken over a decade's worth of research and development to parameterize the human face.
It relies on a universal set of rules for defining the muscular system of the face and utilizes
the proprietary file format called metahuman DNA.
At the core of facial animation, the important elements that the metahuman face rig includes
are the joint and skin weight deformers, blend shape deformers, base and animated texture
setups, the rig logic plugin and metahuman DNA, the user interface of the face control
rig and built in LODs.
In simpler terms, rig logic is what allows animations to be shared by all metahumans
and LODs, while working under the hood to activate blend shapes, corrective blend shapes,
joint transforms and animated maps.
Now we have just gone over the assets that make up the metahuman face.
In the next section, we will take a closer look at metahuman DNA.